Try by day Joe Rogan
podcast by night all day.
How about Oh
God,
Dude.
How about Steve Bay's ground
and pound on over him?
Dude,
overeat.
Thinking about that this whole time,
like how fucking hard did he hit him
with those three shots of shots talking.
Perfect,
perfect place.
Like I was stalking him earlier and he'd
get fucking hitting the guy in the head
and where you to start
him on the triangle.
I'm like fucking day hits.
Steve Bay shots had been fucking
but also Overeem's not exact.
You know he's,
he's his motherboard message board
has been hit a bunch of times.
Well that's why after the fight I said
I don't want to do interviews with
fighters after they got knocked out again.
I appreciate it.
We should never do it all.
I appreciate it that when he said that,
when he said that as I was watching,
I don't fucking talk.
When he said the guy tapped,
I was like,
fuck.
Imagine if he tapped like are we going
to see a task like I had no idea.
You don't,
you don't know if you miss something
during the actual calling of a fight
because it's happening live and it's
so chaotic and it's right after Alister
dropped him,
then he went for the guillotine.
Then all of a sudden
they're on their feet again.
It happened so fast when he said it,
he was so adamant.
We not Scott.
I know.
What about the truck in the back though,
Joe?
Aren't they going Joe,
he didn't tap.
Do you really want to show that?
They don't know.
Fight.
They watched the fight live.
Find out.
So find out where they did you
find out it's entertaining.
It's totally possible.
If he did tap that someone
saw it in the truck,
they would have said it,
but they didn't say it.
But they're like,
we're gonna,
we'll play it for you.
And I said,
okay,
we're gonna,
we're gonna play it.
And so they had a cute up,
they played it and then
he was still insistent.
I'm like,
okay,
well maybe it's the other hand,
but I was thinking,
man,
this is not look good.
And then,
but I'm like,
but it has to be solved.
It has to be resolved.
You know,
when a guy says the guy tapped,
handled to show champion part of the game.
If you check it,
you have to show it,
show it those throat.
But I wish we didn't interview him at all.
I wish,
you know,
I think you guys did have a chance to,
he was completely unconscious and it took
them a while to skip back to his feet
and to have a conversation
with him about the strategy,
about where it went wrong and it's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense
I've ever,
but he doesn't have the leg it all right,
switch it to a dark.
This is a serious shit and got a guy
get losers and it gets submitted it or
whatever.
Fuck,
this sucks.
I wish I would have won even in other
sports like Bennett fl for God's
concussion.
He's not doing interviews,
man.
He's not writing the
head guy breaks his leg.
Ours a need.
They're not interviewing him
because what the is he going to eat?
You don't kind of fucking frame
of mind that guys in dark,
so you're 100% right Joe.
I love that.
Well,
you know it something I had suggested a
long time ago back when we interviewed
Mirko Cro cop after
Gonzaga knocked him out.
I was looking in his eyes that night.
You guys interviewed,
interviewed them right after
the fight and I was like,
we can't do that anymore.
And I said it to him and
we just kept dealing it.
What if it's good for ratings?
Like they get it.
They get knocked out.
Guaranteed interview you want.
They can't be good though.
I'm not doing anything.
They don't even show them
on the ground anymore.
They pan away on the camera.
They tell you a yes or
no Joe or I don't care.
I'm not doing anymore.
You're going to do that.
I'm not doing it,
sir.
I want you guys getting shut.
The fuck you're going to
talk to.
If guys get knocked the fuck out,
if someone really wants to talk to them,
they're going to have to talk to him.
I'm not,
I'm not talking to above was
going to jump in that bitch.
How you fail.
Well,
let's take it from here.
It's time for me to interview you,
Joe.
I'll take it from here.
Thank you,
sir.
I know you hate this part.
I got a raise.
I'm doing it out of respect for the game.
Yeah.
I don't think we need to,
and I don't think,
I think the UFC agrees.
It's just,
it's better for the sport.
What made Alster look bad?
And I think if you gave him a few
hours or even a day to talk about it,
he probably would realize
that that never happened.
It was just,
his brain was scrambled.
Well,
even Steve Bay,
when you're talking to him,
he's like,
hey,
hit me with a kick.
No Sir.
That was a,
well,
he said the guys takes hard,
hard to get a sense of.
Yeah.
Talking about he did get
kicked hard in the body.
He did.
And uh,
I mean,
he could have been mentioning that,
but he probably didn't
realize what knocked him down.
He was concussed to.
Yeah.
Most likely.
Okay.